it was an unusual protest against the
French government's planned pension
reforms members of the Paris Opera
Orchestra played a concert to
demonstrate against the proposals we
wanted to show that our job is to play
music and it makes us unhappy that we've
been forced to strike for a month and
cancel 45 performances for nearly four
weeks people including lawyers teachers
health workers and even ballerinas have
demonstrated against the government's
plans fearing their pensions will be
reduced and they'll be forced to work
longer the Transport Workers strike has
disrupted rail bus and airline services
the French president's been under
pressure to break his silence over the
protests in his New Year's speech he
tried to defuse the crisis nobody can be
bar make no mistake on this important
subject that's so close to French
people's hearts and identity I hear
their fears and anxieties I also hear
many lies and manipulation calm must
always rain come doesn't mean backing
down but respecting each other's
differences
my only compass is and will be the
interests of our country macrame hope
that a speech will end the protests but
workers at this trade union meeting in
Paris said they wouldn't back down
many of the rail workers gathered here
have been on strike since the beginning
of December and they say that the only
thing there will persuade them to go
back to work and in their protest would
be if the government was to scrap its
pension reform plans we started
distracting we plan to finish it because
as long as the government doesn't
restore to reform we'll continue to
strike we are not the only ones
this analyst says that macro has failed
to convince some people that the reforms
are necessary my core has not managed to
isolate the strikers because you know
the pension system is everybody's
problem and he hasn't been convincing
enough I think the lack of trust in the
politicians words in France at the
moment is very cheap and that's the main
problem when Michael says don't worry
everything will be okay you're not going
to lose in this reform people don't
trust him
my craw has a record of pushing through
controversial reforms but this one is
proving particularly challenging the
government says the changes would
modernize the pension system make it
fairer and save public money it will
resume negotiations with trade union
leaders next week but with neither side
showing any sign of backing down the
talks are unlikely to be harmonious
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris